bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte une
chenille défoliant tu la livrée des
forêts sème la destruction dans
certaines érablières cette chenille la a
toujours été présente ici mais les
ravages qu'elle fait alliée à des
conditions climatiques changeantes
peuvent donner le coup de grâce aux
érables
[Musique]
m
on arrive dans la zone où est ce que les
tubes ont été retirés pour céder sur
tout le battage
ce que vit eric filho de mirabel est
contraire au bon sens d'un propriétaire
d'érable à sucre c'est vraiment les
journées les plus chaudes un
acériculteur compris la dernière chose
qu'on peut penser en agenais
on est obligé de couper hamelin
trois jeunes d'une même famille jeudi de
jeter son beau frère éric fillion et son
cousin frédéric jeter ont acheté
l'érablière familiale en 2016 il était
bien parti
déjà l'obtention de la certification
biologique et l'or pour le bon goût de
leur sirop puis une petite chenille
indigènes a frappé de manière brutale
la livrée des forêts
des 76 hectares d'érable en production
six hectares ont été attaqués en juin
1500 érable sont déjà morts les
boisements on espère que les repousses
génération n'est pas pour vous
ici et là un érable attaquer mais encore
debout je dit je t'ai s'accroche
normalement saisir un bloc qui reste en
plein milieu tout seul le faire de la
com sont à moitié fait qu ont les
auraient abattus mais là on les garde
pour nous les feuilles vertes qu'on voit
la ccrc de l'espoir
l'insecte est le plus important ravageur
de feuillus au pays
il s'attaque d'abord aux feuilles du
pilier faux trombe
puis à celle du chêne dufresne du
bouleau blanc ou de l'érable le toujours
des populations des vrais des forêts
même quand on les voit pas mais en
moyenne ou neuf ans dans copier feront
trembler ou 13 ans dans les érablières
les populations commencent à augmenter
et cause des épidémies
efolia sion de quelques années a faibli
honorable mais n'est pas censé le faire
mourir dans l'érable à sucre à ma
connaissance est une des premières fois
on voit une mortalité aussi importante
les infestations sont localisés mais ces
vins ce que voient la lumière car
halabja c'est pas comme ça
habituellement les phénomènes el habib
allah ce temps signalé un goût pour la
veille dans ce film
les voisins des jetés michel lalande et
sa femme brigitte sont revenus en 2014 à
la ferme paternelle de mirabel pour
vivre une deuxième carrière
cette nouvelle ville réussit et leur
sert aux est récompensé
mais chez eux aussi la livre et a frappé
un dur coup dans notre cas nous ça
représente notre le menu principal sur
la ferme donc c'est pas comme justin un
appoint ou ne les ont pas l'aparté
longtemps déçus
dans leur peuplement la livrée des
forêts a détruit 900 et ra ble en tout
près de 25% de leur sert à blanc taille
et ont été touchés le dépérissement a
été foudroyant ont selon l'aveu tapis de
petites feuilles m'a fait de faire
couper par les chenilles qui on
l'entendait les fientes des chenilles
tomber comme s'il pleuvait les grands
érables ont été vus chez ne reste que
les souches
michel lalande tout comme la famille
jeter a consulté des experts
les avis étaient claires un érable
résiste sans problème à une défoliation
modérée de la livrée pendant deux ou
trois ans vous aurez à l'été 2007 on a
une défoliation qui était majeure puis
mais on croyait que les filles étaient
pour le pousser c'est ce que les
ingénieurs forestiers me disait on
disait basse et laissez la nature lyon
des prédateurs
puis les arbres sont quand même les il
ya puis au printemps 2010 8 l'opération
s'est rendu compte que pour cette
feuille d érable donc qui était vraiment
mort
eric filho aussi accru la survie de ses
érables au premier échelon
on la voyait apparaître en première
année on s'est dit on une défoliation
certain pourcentage on dirait peut-être
1 25% de défoliation tolérable on n'a
pas vu de conséquences en tant que tel
on l'a tolérée ce n'est pas que les
méthodes de championnat j'étais quand
même moins sophistiquée que nous
si la chenille seul n'entraîne pas la
mort elle peut porter le coup fatal dans
certaines conditions
le stress causé par cet insecte à l'eau
pendant plusieurs années peut entraîner
la manche et des armes qui sont
affaiblis les arbres sains normalement
résiste très bien aux attaques à des
vénérables pour tous aux yeux des
propriétaires de mirabel les érables
mort avait l'apparence d'ardres
vigoureux pas du tout affaibli le
secteur ici avaient toutes été aménagé à
9 2 à 9 ans c'était notre secteur
d'avenir c'est des belles gérable en
pleine croissance et des élèves de
wright point acériculteurs de l'avis des
experts le drainage du sol était un
parfait
un beau exister la présence de plantes
particulière dans le peuplement comme
les fougères le sureau et les frênes
pour faire attention les arbres peuvent
avoir l'air sain mais il perd quand même
à titre et c'est suffisamment pour que
le livre des forêts puisse avoir un
effet un impact très important sur eux
et surtout un autre élément a été
déterminant le climat
d'abord enfin les facteurs prédisposants
comme un mauvais drainage au niveau des
sols un facteur déclenchant qui est
l'épidémie de les livrer mais il ya
aussi des facteurs aggravants qui sont
être associés justement des extrêmes
climatiques qui ont neuf subies on le
sait depuis quelques années des coudes
et donc des précipitations très
importantes qu'on voyait pas aux trois
fois ces épisodes de pluies abondantes
de 2017 et 2018 sont survenus dans des
peuplements déjà fragilisé avec la libre
et c'en était trop
[Musique]
dans des sols mal drainé pas ça finit
par causer ni plus ni moins qu'une dose
suffit que si des arbres et lorsqu'un
deuxième stress qui est embarqué sur le
sur ces mêmes arbres renault des
centaines la mortalité rapide
l'inventaire annuel du ministère
québécois des forêts démontrent une
augmentation des airs infestée par la
livrée des forêts à divers degrés en
2010 7 306 mail hectares de forêt des
folies ont été observées en 2018
la superficie totale atteignait 390
mille hectares les principales zones
touchées se situaient dans les
laurentides l'outaouais et l'estrie
d'autres foyers sont apparus dans
lanaudière en montérégie et au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean
depuis 1938 le ministère a répertorié 8
d'épidémie de la livre et l'épidémie la
plus importante a été celle des années
50 avec eux mêmes plus important que ce
qu'on a vu au cours des dernières années
infestation importante oui mais pas
nécessairement mortels le père de michel
lalande s'en souvient vraiment pas là 81
3 1 depuis il s'appelle kalinka keita
petit goâve donc probablement autour de
15 ans qu' il y avait vu ces chenilles
ou pis dans des quantités astronomiques
mais y'avait pas constater où il
s'appelle pas qu'un menu ce
dépérissement ou des d'amore d'érable
cette fois ci le contexte climatique
n'est plus le même dans le fond nos
écosystèmes sont en train de sortir de
leur condition où ils ont évolué
historiquement et c'est pour ça que les
policiers fixe est difficile de prédire
ce qui va se passer parce que le pass
n'est plus garant d'avenir il existe
pourtant un prédateur indigènes de la
livrée des forêts la mouche sarcophage
or elle n'a pas eu le temps d'être
efficace c'est un insecte qui va penser
eux sur les larves
ah ah j'aime et y vivent qui va surtout
se développer dans le cocon de l'inseec
a cité son cas qu'on va passer à l'étape
pétillon qui votent oui 80 90 % des
livres et sait comment se fait-il
philippot fait son travail
ben là c'est que on est on est pas en
fin d'épidémie dans le cas présent on a
eu deux années de déflation modérée
normalement c'est loin d'être une fin
d'épidémie aurait dû durer encore une
année ou deux années supplémentaires en
attendant un insecticide existe c'est le
btk le même et s'est hissé de naturel
utilisé contre la tordeuse des bourgeons
de l'épinette certains acériculteurs ont
payé des arrosages et pour plusieurs neu
btk à enrayer le problème
nous on pense que c'est une solution
doit être utilisée en dernier recours
pour g et évaluer la rentabilité des
arrosages parce que ça coûte cher faut
éviter d'arroser pour rien
[Musique]
bien sûr eric fillion ne peut pas
remonter dans le temps mais ça le
regrette amèrement de ne pas avoir
investi dans un traitement aux bété cas
aujourd'hui c'est là que le seul moyen
qu'on arrête priori n'a pu s'arrêter d
arroser les traités pour réussir à
contrôler au moins la population de
livrer avec les extrêmes climatiques des
dernières années la pensée du chercheur
hébert quant aux méthodes de lutte a
évolué
peut-être qu'on devra intervenir ce qu
on se refusait à faire jusqu'à tout
récemment avec des arrosages opt pour
contrôler le stress déclencheur que pour
être l'épidémie ainsi qu'on parle de
livrer mais ça pourrait d'autres
insectes qui peut là l'occasion dans les
érablières
chose certaine frederik je t on a plein
les bras
la destinée des érables à sucre a battu
est maintenant de devenir du bois de
chauffage
ça fait des jeux au moins deux semaines
que la fendeuse à marche bancarel toute
la journée 40 par semaine mais ton pire
j'imagine encore moins deux trois
semaines temps plein encore le dessus
l'argent de la vente du bois de
chauffage ne couvrira que la location de
l'équipement pour toute l'opération de
buch âge
et ne compensera jamais les pertes de la
vente du sirop l'érable à sucre mais au
moins trente ou quarante ans avant
d'atteindre 20 centimètres le diamètre
de l'entaillage le manque à gagner des
jeux t est considérable si je fais la
moyenne de nos trois dernières années en
termes de livres à l'entaillé sas
figurerait au pauvre 25000 dollars de
pertes financières par année pendant
[Musique]
en santé et sans avarie l'érable aurait
pu donner de la cev quelques centaines
d'années
aujourd'hui je dit je t'ai tient à
mettre en garde tous les acériculteurs
contre la chenille sa mortalité dans les
érablières souhaitent un passage très
souvent des livres et des forêts que les
gens soir à l'affût aux aguets qui
surveille larzet impliqués qu'ils aient
pas arroser aussi un appel à la
vigilance partagé par le chercheur c'est
certain que je dirais que l'on devrait
plus inquiet aujourd'hui qu'il ya deux
ans où il ya cinq ans
finalement à la fin de l'été les arbres
marquis du vert de l'espoir de judith
sont morts
ce devait être même 500 érables ce sera
plutôt 1800 érables à sucre qui seront
abattus
[Applaudissements]
la livrée du forez n'a pas ébranlé
michel lalande au point et de remettre
en question son choix de vie on est bien
on aime soit on a confiance que ça va
continuer pour s'adapte avec ce qui est
le cas pas le choix
[Musique]